the u.s has the cheeseburger vietnam has
the bon me
mexico has the torta and india has the
vada pao
a sandwich beloved by millions so
beloved in fact mcdonald's tried to
emulate it with their mikalu tiki burger
however unsuccessful so let me introduce
you
to the vadapot
this is the vada the best way to
describe it
it is deep fried mashed potato it is
spiced but not too spicy
and always served hot
and this is the pow the pow is the bread
it should slightly deflate when you poke
it
and there's the chutney there is some
debate around how much there should be
but one thing is for certain it needs to
be there
so with that in mind we are going to
three places with
three different takes on the sandwich
starting with the inventor's son
my name is narendra shoka and i sell
vadappa
at dada in mumbai my father had started
this
vadapa in 1966. the vadapo was already
existing
but i think he was the first person to
actually put it inside the
power and just give a punch to it okay
this is your vada
when the word bombi comes it is
definitely linked to vada power
mumbai is vadhaka it's a favorite food
of everybody
it's quite filling two vada powers is
like as good as one dinner
and one is like your breakfast
next we're going to call this the
popular one
[ __ ] whatever store
foreign
and finally this is the modern one
this is gupta i run jambo king we are
the largest what about chain in mumbai
city
damoken is known as the company which
branded the varapara
the schezwan jambo king nachos jambo
king paneer jambo king there's a double
decker jambo king
it's different from the street kai
because we are way more hygienic and
it's the innovation that people really
love
it is a sin to tamper with the original
dish but we have committed that sin way
too many times
so we now have eight different types of
jumbo kings it's an awesome combination
this whole story boils down to one thing
no matter which way you serve it or
where you
buy it you should be eating it because
it is
[Music]
amazing
you